petit typ en finale avec un focus sur
les pions électriques les pions
électriques sont des pions passés mais
séparés par une rangée contrairement au
pions passéliers qui peuvent se protéger
l'un l'autre les pions électriques sembl
souvent vulnérables pour le roi ennemi
il n'en est rien si vous les maniez avec
précision ici on va prendre cet exemple
les noir jouerait roi C4 pour attaquer
le pion C3 mais on pourrait jouer A4 et
si le roi capture le pion alors il sort
du carré et notre pion a va filet à Dame
donc dans cette position le roi est
obligé de reculer et aucun de nous de
pions est pris c'est donc le bon moment
pour ramener notre propre monarque petit
à petit vers la bataille le roi va
tenter de contourner pour s'en prendre
au pion à4 et maintenant il faut pousser
l'autre pion et l'idée c'est que si le
roi va d'un côté nous on va pousser de
l'autre s'il va en C5 on va pousser à 5
regardez l'illustration roi à 5 pour
attaquer à 4 on pousse C5 et le même
manège que tout à l'heure recommence il
ne peut pas manger sous peine de sortir
du carré et cette fois-ci c'est notre
pionc qui se transforme en fusée pour
nous offrir la
victoire